>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Nicholas Brown: Hi everyone.
I hoped you enjoyed the concert.
My name is Nick Brown [applause].
I didn't do anything
especial, it was all her.
We're so pleased to
have Anne Sofie here
to spend some time with you all.
Well, just I'll start off
with a couple of questions
and then we'll open
it up to all of you
and hopefully our colleagues
will join shortly.
This is a very interesting
program, in terms of the mix
of contemporary popular
artists as well
as the earlier Renaissance
and Baroque music.
Is this something new for you,
to mix up the types of music?
Or have you been doing
it for a while?
>> Anne Sofie von Otter: I mix
-- I frequently mix the composers
and the genres in my
concert programs
because I enjoy it very
much myself, and then I hope
that the audience does too.
And there are plenty
of other singers
who put together different
types of more specialized --
I mean only Schubert or
only the German Romantics.
So this is also always been my --
it's always given me a
lot of pleasure to mix,
to vary the programs
and [inaudible] only
in English Renaissance music I
wouldn't even want to do that.
So this is my little cook-up.
And because the musicians
are so fabulous,
they can play these
other types as well.
>> Nicholas Brown: Wonderful.
Can you tell us how you three
came to start working together?
>> Anne Sofie von Otter:
Oh, there they are.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible Response ]
[ Background Conversations ]
Yes. Well, I have sung
quite a lot in Paris,
with the different [inaudible]
there, and Thomas lives in Paris.
And so we met each other
for the first time five
years ago or something.
And I noticed this young man,
how extremely talented he was.
And he also liked to fool around
and then you know we
would do a pop song.
And so I thought he's the guy.
And I tell you that not every
lute player has such freedom
as you do, as Thomas does.
And then we needed a third person.
And I had never worked
with you before.
But I think you said, and other
people said, to ask Jonathan Cohen.
He's fantastic.
So I did, and it turned out
that these two knew each other
really well.
They love playing together.
And Jonathan is a conductor,
not only a keyboard
player and a cello player.
He's also a conductor.
That's what you do.
>> Jonathan Cohen:
That's right [laughter].
>> Anne Sofie von Otter:
Maybe more than [inaudible].
So anyway, you knew each other,
and it was the perfect combo.
And I just love these guys.
They are so wonderful.
They're really such musicians
and such freedom and so nice.
And I wish we could -- I hope we
can do a lot more concerts together.
>> Nicholas Brown:
Wonderful [inaudible].
Has there been a highlight
from this tour,
in terms of a specific performance
or a specific venue or
a specific audience?
Assuming that this is
the best, of course.
>> Anne Sofie von Otter: We were
just talking about that [inaudible].
>> Nicholas Brown: Jonathan.
>> Jonathan Cohen: Well, you
know when we go on tours,
especially as a keyboard player,
you often have sometimes
very different instruments
in different places.
I have to say tonight I really
enjoyed the fantastic harpsichord
and organ that we had here.
So that was a real
highlight for me to be able
to play these instruments.
>> Thomas Dunford Duration:
I loved all of them
and they were all different.
This one was [inaudible].
But Philadelphia was fun.
The first one was wow
[inaudible] they were all different
and there but I love them all.
>> Nicholas Brown: Have you
two toured much in the US?
Separately I know you've
been in here,
in Washington recently and such.
>> Jonathan Cohen: Yeah.
I come to the US reasonably
regularly in different guises.
I work a lot with the [foreign
accent] in Minnesota and come
to New York with my ensemble.
[foreign accent] always
love coming to the US.
The audiences are very friendlier.
And I find people enjoy classical
music a lot here in the venues
that we come to, like
here, for example.
It's great.
>> Nicholas Brown: Are there
plans for the three of you
to tour further in the future?
>> Anne Sofie von Otter: In
our heads, yes [laughter].
>> Nicholas Brown: Wonderful.
What for Anne Sofie --
what is an important thing
that you hope US audiences gain
from the Nordic music that you share
when you perform over here?
Because I think a lot
of the composers aren't
so familiar to us over here.
>> Anne Sofie von Otter: Nordic.
You mean when I do other
recitals with Nordic music?
>> Nicholas Brown: Yeah.
>> Anne Sofie von Otter:
Well, Nordic music,
a lot of it is extremely
beautiful and has a certain --
its own character and
the text and everything.
Of course, Swedish
is my own language,
but the songs are exceptionally
good.
Grieg, the Norwegian
composer, Grieg, Sibelius.
And Sweden doesn't have
a big name like that,
but we have I don't know five,
10 different fantastic
[inaudible] composers.
So I almost always include
them in my programs,
and I know that the audience
really take them to heart.
>> Nicholas Brown: Wonderful.
Thank you.
I think we'll just switch it over
to ask -- you can ask questions now.
If you could just raise your hand
and wait for a microphone to come
to you that would be great.
You all didn't have a drink before,
did you [inaudible] [laughter]?
>> Anne Sofie, you did an
album with Elvis Costello.
What was that like?
>> Anne Sofie von Otter: Well,
Elvis is a really fantastic guy.
He's got so much experience.
He's really, really clever and is a
very creative person, as you know --
anyone who knows Elvis Costello.
I mean he does all kinds of
things and plays and sings
with all different kinds of people.
And he's just written
a fantastic book.
So it was a great pleasure
to work with him.
We had got to know each other
several years before we recorded,
so I really felt that this
was someone I could trust.
And he'd been to many, many concerts
at different classical
music that I'd sung.
And we started discussing what
kind of pop music I liked and why.
And why I didn't like other kinds.
So it was sent in cassettes.
This was the day of the cassettes,
so it sent back and forth.
So all in all it was a
very wonderful experience
and he really knew what he was
doing, doing this you know he had --
the putting my voice
in the right context
and choosing the good songs
for the disc together.
>> Nicholas Brown: Yes.
My microphone runner
disappeared but [inaudible] --
>> Audience Speaker: So I actually
have a question for all of you.
Is there some decent music
that -- is that better?
>> Yes.
>> Audience Speaker: I had
a question for all of you.
Is there some piece of music
that you have really
always wanted to perform?
Or perhaps a role Anne Sofie
that you have always wanted to do
but it hasn't yet come to fruition?
What is your white
[inaudible], if you were?
[ Laughter ]
[ Background Conversations ]
>> Anne Sofie von Otter: Well
I've had a very long career.
And I've been very lucky, and I've
done most of the things I wanted to.
And there are few things that I
would like to do but which are not
for my voice, unfortunately.
Well, unfortunately I've been --
you know I've had such a wonderful
career doing the kinds amazing roles
and pieces with wonderful
conductors, so I can't even say
at the time I'm happy
or bitter or anything.
I'm doing now contemporary or
[inaudible] I used to because well,
the composers will maybe write
with me in mind, which is nice.
[Inaudible] and I'm doing a Finnish
opera in [inaudible] opera, right?
Yeah. So that kind of music,
but otherwise I feel fulfilled.
[ Laughter ]
What would you like to do
that you're not [inaudible]?
>> Thomas Dunford Duration:
Everything that I haven't
played [laughter].
Any style.
I'd like to do classical.
I'd like to later stuff.
I'd like to play Mozart,
Beethoven, [foreign name].
I'd like to play jazz,
rock [inaudible] try
out on lutes many different things.
There's a lot to play.
>> Jonathan Cohen: Well for me,
I'd love to do the height
and creation [phonetic].
That's something that
I haven't done.
I really love that piece and it's
like an ambition of mine to do that.
And [foreign name], in general.
Actually in the Baroque stuff I
don't know [inaudible] and that kind
of early Baroque German music.
I haven't done so much of that
and I think it's fantastic.
So lots of things yet
to do for me but --
>> Anne Sofie von Otter: You're
both so young [laughter].
I have -- may I ask a question?
How come you don't chew [phonetic]
all the time during the concert
because I've done some concerts
with [foreign names] lute before.
There's a [making lute sound]
several times during the concert.
It takes a quite a
long time every time.
Now, you have not done this
once, I don't think [laughter].
And so I wondered is it because
your lute is so well built
that it keeps its tuning?
Or do you play a little -- you know
you change where your finger is
so then -- because you can hear
I need to play a little higher.
How come?
>> Thomas Dunford Duration:
It's technology.
No. It's just because 300
years ago we used gut strings.
And they were very good at making
gut strings, especially for lutes.
And they were specific and
really great and kept the tuning.
But it was an art, so
like Stradivarius' process
for making wood with violin.
It was very -- a real art
that's been a bit lost.
And I'm not very satisfied with
the sound of gut strings now
because it's all made
in factories and stuff
so it doesn't sound as,
on the lute, as nice.
So I just used synthetic strings,
which most lute players use
because if you'd go on
tour San Francisco to --
from LA to Washington and every
day go in different places.
And you guys would spend your
life listening to tuning.
It'd be really boring.
>> Anne Sofie von Otter: So
it's because of the strings.
>> Thomas Dunford Duration:
The strings are good.
And when you change
them, it moves a bit.
But then it settles down,
and it doesn't move too much.
Yeah.
>> Anne Sofie von Otter:
I also would like to know how
long can you play on this lute?
It looks like it's been quite used
a lot, a little wear and tear.
And do you use it -- is there a
moment when the lute has had enough
and you have to throw it away?
Or do you then renovate
it and put on new polish
and change a few things,
and then it's good as new?
>> Thomas Dunford Duration:
Well, I really love this lute.
I had it when I was 14.
And I've been playing it all the
time since -- when I first got it.
Wow. This thing's got a
resonance and it was amazing.
It was a young wow.
Now it's an old guy
who's seen the world,
and I really love him,
as he's still great.
Love it. But he's dying.
>> Anne Sofie von Otter:
Is that a fact?
>> Thomas Dunford Duration: No.
But he -- you know like
the table is really used.
That it's been hit, and it doesn't
have the same youth it used to have.
And lutes are -- it's very fragile.
So they tend to -- I
hope he doesn't die soon.
So I'm going to do everything
I can to take care of this,
but I've been playing
too much all over --
like on beaches and
wrong places [laughter].
>> Anne Sofie von Otter:
So that's what I mean.
I mean you would never stop
using a cello or a violin.
You would give it to the
whatever it's called,
the shop where they
make good as new, right?
>> Jonathan Cohen: He was
practicing in Central Park
in New York a couple of days ago.
Just under a tree.
>> Nicholas Brown: Did you
make any money [inaudible]?
>> Thomas Dunford Duration: No.
[ Laughter ]
>> Nicholas Brown: A question
following up on that for Anne Sofie.
How have you noticed your voice
evolve throughout your career
and have you done anything
specific to kind of --
>> Anne Sofie von Otter: Well, I
work very hard now that I'm older.
I've always been quite disciplined
but never as disciplined as now.
I can tell you, if I wouldn't
practice and keep my voice --
work very hard with it -- I
would have to retire immediately
because at my age the
voice really wants to be
like the rest of the
body [inaudible].
So you have to hold it up,
up, up, up, up [laughter].
It's true.
I'm not fibbing.
This is very -- I mean if I just
let it go, it goes wow, wow, wow.
So to be able to sing Baroque
music and straight tones
and [inaudible] it's
just very hard work.
You have to be very -- you have
to think about what you're doing.
>> Nicholas Brown: How does your
warm-up differ from a program
like this versus the
Mahler that you performed
at the Kennedy Center
a few weeks ago?
Or is it the same?
>> Anne Sofie von Otter: Well,
for Mahler Third Symphony,
which I did a week ago with
a wonderful orchestra here
and Christoph Eschenbach.
It was a huge experience.
It was very intense and I loved it.
But to prepare for that the
instrument is bigger, so to speak,
and I need to warm up in a bigger
way because I sing differently.
So I still need to warm up.
Of course, for this but
then when I go out on stage,
I sing in a much more contained way.
The warming up itself
is not so different.
>> Nicholas Brown: Any
other audience questions?
Yep. One second.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Audience Speaker:
I was very pleased
to hear you mention Eva Cassidy.
And I was just curious to know how
you came to discover her music?
>> Anne Sofie von Otter:
Yeah, Eva Cassidy --
I wonder if her friend didn't say
have you heard of Eva Cassidy?
I think so.
And then I was hunting around
for Simon and Garfunkel songs,
and on Spotify, her name came up.
And I recognized the name.
And I listened and
then it's so beautiful,
and I went out to buy a disc.
But I, and most of the world,
didn't know who she was
when she was still alive.
Apparently she really wasn't
famous outside Washington.
And then somebody did
put together some songs
or made a program about her.
And then she -- you know people
heard how beautifully she sang.
But she didn't -- she had a --
you know she [inaudible] so much
in a much tougher way, but she
really knew how to use her voice.
It's very sad that
she died so early.
>> Nicholas Brown: Time
for one more question.
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Anne Sofie von Otter:
Music education
in Sweden is terrible [laughter].
It really, really is.
I mean at least, if you're
thinking classical music,
musical education [inaudible]
in a broader sense why this is.
But a lot of people still sing
in choirs, all different kinds
of choirs, and so -- but [inaudible]
phenomenon is still is incredible.
I mean there are so many.
It's not just [inaudible]
somebody called the red one,
and my son's trying
to do the same thing.
So this is now a kind of -- I
guess we all learn from each other.
But no, unfortunately the
music education, I think,
in most countries but maybe
not in France or in Germany
but in most other countries --
>> Jonathan Cohen: Yeah.
Well, in England, there's a big
campaign at the moment to try
to get music much more in
schools for kids and for everyone
when they're young to do it.
And I think it's so important
because if you have familiarity
with that in your youth,
then that's a real pleasure
to be able to do that your life.
Whether you do it professionally
or not and maybe the audience
of the future, you
know it's important.
You know, it's important, I think,
so important that kids [inaudible]
to music even if they don't want
to do anything after a while.
That they should be given
the chance, so important.
>> Nicholas Brown: In France?
>> Thomas Dunford Duration: Yeah.
It was good.
But the thing is when you learn
in a conservatory or anything,
there intends to be something very
rigid about the way of learning
about -- this is harmony.
You have to learn four, four
and three, three, and you forget
about five, seven,
Indian music, jazz,
improvisation, and all this stuff.
And they tend to have
this thing of schools.
We are the best school.
You have to stay in
school and study here.
But actually music -- the best
experiences is playing with people.
And that's how I learned even more.
It's good for giving a basis,
but I think schools don't
do everything as well.
It's also experience.
>> Anne Sofie von Otter: Sure.
>> Thomas Dunford Duration: So --
but I was very lucky in France.
They have good systems for that
where you can go to class half-time
and conservatory half-time.
And you get to meet young
guys who play saxophone
and teach you jazz, and it's great.
I was happy.
>> Nicholas Brown: Do you ever go
to jam sessions with your lute?
>> Thomas Dunford Duration: Yeah.
>> Nicholas Brown: Nice [laughter].
Next time you're in DC, you'll
have to do one at some club
and we'll all go over there.
>> Thomas Dunford Duration: Okay.
Great.
>> Nicholas Brown: Wonderful.
Well, thank you to Thomas, to Anne
Sofie and to Jonathan for joining us
up here [inaudible] do
you still have the cds?
Has he gone already?
Okay. Nevermind.
No more cds, unfortunately, but
you can go online and find them.
Thank you again for a wonderful
performance and for speaking with --
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.